this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up guys helen here christmas
season is in full swing with twinkle
lights and red coffee cups everywhere
you turn and if a truly never-ending
stream of holiday content is your bag
you already know there's no better place
to find it than the hallmark channel
every year they release so many new
christmas movies that if you watched one
a day you still wouldn't be able to get
through them all between thanksgiving
and christmas itself which is not a
problem for me because i put my tree up
on arbor day hallmark's holiday movies
are watched by tens of millions of
christmas cheer seeking folks every year
more than 80 million in 2018 to be
precise the demand for these movies
makes sense who doesn't love looking at
hot people and cozy sweaters as they
fall in love under the watchful eye of a
parasitic plant but why have these uh
less than nuanced depictions of american
christmas remained so essential to the
holiday in our cultural imagination
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
how hallmark stole christmas and
spoilers ahead for a whole bunch of
hallmark movies but before we get into
it i want to tell you about this week's
sponsor surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn helps
you secure your data with
industry-leading measures by using
uncrackable encryption and the most
secure vpn protocols one of the things i
love most about surfshark is that it
keeps my location totally private and
that can have huge advantages like
accessing streaming content that's only
been released in other countries so i
can keep up with new movies and shows
before they reach the us and it keeps
airlines from gouging me on inflated
ticket prices based on my location too
instead i can connect my secure
surfshark vpn to other vpns in different
countries until i track down the best
deal one subscription covers all of your
favorite devices like your laptop
android amazon fire stick playstation
and more plus you can still use your
favorite apps too like chrome and
firefox get started by clicking the link
in the description and using the promo
code wisecrack when you do you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus four extra
months for free go to searchshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show to understand the hallmark
christmas movie industrial complex we
need to look at the history of christmas
in america while christmas celebrations
first hit planet earth around 336 ce the
holiday wasn't really seen as that
sacred or that big of a deal for most of
its history in fact as historian judith
flanders points out christmas has always
been a secular holiday with the
religious component tacked on see humans
have always celebrated the dead of
winter with massive festivals featuring
copious consumption so early christians
basically kept the tradition going added
a virginal birth and called it a day but
it wasn't until after the civil war that
christmas and all its glorious
commodification truly found its place in
the u.s before christmas was loosely
celebrated in america at best and was
entirely shunned by certain segments of
christianity puritans for instance
didn't party down because it wasn't
mentioned in the bible and also because
they were worried it was more about
partying than piousness but after the
civil war it became the end-all be-all
of cozy family togetherness tldr
homesick lonely soldiers latched on to
christmas as something comforting to
daydream about while out on the
battlefield and their families wishing
they were safe at home followed suit the
more everybody thought about the joy of
christmas the more idealized it became
in the popular imagination so when
families were reunited for their first
christmas after the war all of that
yearning had an outlet and america's
basically been chasing that same holiday
high ever since around the same time a
considerable force in creating the
secular commercialized vision of
christmas was the post-war rise of the
department store by the 1890s people
could easily get mass-produced goods at
these temples of consumption at low
prices or on credit and that
revolutionized retail and the way we
celebrate christmas all at once
christmas stopped being the exclusive
purview of the church and started also
being a commercial extravaganza
associated with weeks of shopping
decorating and getting into the
christmas spirit plenty of people did
and obviously still do take the jesus
part of the holiday seriously too but
it's hard to ignore the allure of
clothes treat yourself fragrances treat
yourself massage it treat yourself
mimosas treat yourself fine leather
goods treat yourself and by the early
years of the 20th century it was
standard practice for any retail
establishment to offer christmas items
and to dress up their shops and festive
symbols of the season the macy's
thanksgiving day parade began in 1924
and with the help of television has come
to usher in the christmas season for
america and here's a fun fact that blew
my holly jolly mind the u.s even shifted
the concept of time for christmas's sake
in 1939 president franklin deck the
halls roosevelt officially moved
thanksgiving back a week why because
christmas was such a big deal that
several big companies put pressure on
him to give people an extra week of
christmas shopping time so as
christmas's headquarters suddenly split
between the church and the department
store it became increasingly secularized
and as a result it came to be accepted
as a universal american experience
because what says universal american
experience more than trying to
assimilate to its culture the pronounced
relationship between christmas and the
concept of proper assimilation actually
dates back to victorian england in
victorian christmas literature outsiders
are often marked as strange by their
ignorance of or hostility to british
christmas traditions but with a little
holiday spirit these outsiders are
eventually welcomed into the feast a
sort of shorthand for learning to be
properly british comes with embracing
christmas and celebrating its customs
properly around the same time americans
zeroed in on england's christmas customs
and that's largely thanks to a certain
20-year nap enthusiast named washington
irving his popular book of essays the
sketchbook of jeffrey crayon gent
features a british gentleman who invites
all the farm workers on his estate to
join him for a coziest hell christmas
feast and rich people in america really
ran with this idea by throwing feasts
organizing hunts and generally doing
stuff that they imagined rich brits did
during the holiday and these american
riffs on the mythology of a classic
christmas were here to stay so an
emphasis on embracing christmas and
properly celebrating its customs you say
where have we heard that before that's
right the hallmark channel your typical
hallmark christmas movie follows a few
standard plot lines repeated ad
infinitum woman who lives in the big
city ends up in a small town by some
circumstance like a breakup or a family
obligation at first she butts heads with
a headstrong small town boy you look
familiar i'm glad you think this is
funny mr carter cause i don't
i don't like being made fun of i wasn't
i find it disrespectful and totally
unprofessional but eventually she falls
in love with him and with the town's
wholesome values and decides to stay or
say have you heard the one about the
main character who stops believing in
christmas magic or is just going through
some kind of crisis but through an
encounter with another character who
very well may actually be santa an angel
or an elf the protagonist gets their
jingle bells back did you drive your car
out here
uh
something like that christmas is not
just sitting in a big house watching the
festivities through the window or this
one which is shown up far beyond
hallmark an american commoner perhaps
one who's employed as a nanny or stylist
meets the prince of a fictional foreign
land she then charms him out of his
stodgy ways by introducing him to both
the joys of american style christmas and
her hot bod in the ball gown and then
there's that old chestnut where a
corporation or just a really rich person
tries to change or destroy a small
town's christmas traditions but the
person they send in to take over falls
in love with a local they then convince
their corporate overlords that these
traditions are worth preserving after
all you get the gist now throw in a few
baking contests the occasional case of
amnesia a few instances of bringing home
a fake boyfriend and you've basically
got yourself a hallmark christmas too in
the hallmark universe there's nothing a
little christmas spirit can't solve but
the reliance on small town vibes
anti-corporatism and humble spirit is
somewhat illusory that's because
hallmark christmas movies thrive in this
weird liminal space between rampant
consumerism and anti-materialism sure
our protagonists start out in high-power
jobs but these films often culminate
with said protagonists often women
realizing that their careers and
presumably financial independence don't
hold a candle to the love of a humble
hometown hunk and this makes a weird
kind of sense these movies are
functionally vehicles to make us feel so
nostalgic that we drop 100 bucks on a
new christmas tree skirt but at the same
time we're being encouraged by the
storylines to take a cue from the
children retirees and other
free-spirited characters to recognize
the spiritual necessity of not working
when is eve leaving
sometime after christmas that's really
close
if she was just superintendent
would she stay a bit contradictory am i
right what's more in hallmark films any
material problems presented like a
charity needs money are solved through
the generosity of a benevolent wealthy
individual did you authorize that a
portion of all toy sales go to support
children whose parents serve in the
military
yes
good job this conveniently sidesteps any
commentary on say a need for structural
change so that more people can afford
christmas gifts and like basic needs too
this is another hand-me-down that
america borrowed from victorian england
the class attitudes during victoria's
reign were reflected in the literature
of folks like mary elizabeth bradden
noted ragamuffin enthusiast charles
dickens and augustus and henry mayhew
their work focused on income inequality
and poor people's suffering but appealed
to the reader to redistribute their
wealth to those in need after all a
christmas carol doesn't end in
revolutionary action to overthrow
oppressive systems that take advantage
of workers instead it ends with one rich
man seeing the light and being less
stingy specifically with his employees
and local charity seekers these authors
use the christmas season to teach their
readers a lesson about their
responsibilities as people with means
and we see this duality in hallmark
movies too like in christmas cookies
when a corporate overlord visits a small
town in order to shut down the local
cookie factory but then the spirit of
christmas convinces her to save this
pillar of the community and to fall in
love with this guy but this is only the
beginning of all the subtle ways that
hallmark is so damn good at what it does
consider this these movies further
negotiate the tension between crass
consumption and anti-materialist spirit
of christmas by evoking a less
complicated time how through the
emotional power of nostalgia which is
intrinsic to christmas according to
flanders as flanders says nostalgia is
not a byproduct it's part of christmas
it is part of the holiday to believe
that in the past it was better whichever
way we look whether we're looking at
norman rockwell pictures charles dickens
novels or medieval feasts it is an
essential core element of the holiday to
believe it was better in the past in
fact flanders first found mention of
people being nostalgic for a mythical
christmas past circa 1605 and that feels
like a legit reason why hallmark's
popularity would endure in today's bad
vibes party millennials in particular
might be especially susceptible to what
journalist jeb lund calls hontology the
nostalgia for lost futures lund argues
that there are people who didn't grow up
in hallmarks america and can never move
there because they lack the money and
the time machine required if
homeownership leisure and making a
comfortable living doing crafts and blue
collar work remain a fantasy they are an
even more powerful fantasy for people
with postgraduate degrees six-figure
debt cratering industries and no help on
the horizon as lun points out it's
pretty cold of america to make us expect
a christmas that matches the hype of
those civil war era celebrations it can
really bring your real life into stark
relief and sometimes that feels pretty
damn bleak now fans of hallmark films
are often very open about how they're
comfort food they do not challenge the
viewer or force them to think about
divisive topics rather they're decidedly
trying to be apolitical there is no
critical race theory in the hallmark
world cops barely exist because who
needs them when everything is perfect
but if they do show up they're the hunky
love interest like in the candace
cameron bird 2016 time travel flick
journey back to christmas very rarely
does jesus even get name dropped and
there's no poverty that can't be solved
by a bake sale or a toy drive because
people are more than happy to organize
such magnanimous events and even when a
hallmark movie does something totally
outlandish like featuring a queer couple
or main characters who aren't
exclusively rich and white they still
don't challenge the overall narrative of
christmas the one where it's the
ultimate american experience and the one
which most reflects our national values
i mean heck even the fleeting hanukkah
themed films use the same imagery
because no matter which way you slice
this yule log these movies nostalgia and
simulation of american christmases past
serves to reinforce our idea of
christmas as intrinsic to some magical
american spirit even or maybe especially
when the traditions being depicted
aren't necessarily religious hallmark
christmas movies are teaching us what it
means to be american they codify rituals
they're not simply selling greeting
cards and ornaments during commercial
breaks they're selling viewers a vision
of real america christmas traditions
aren't just warm fuzzy and nostalgic but
part of the experience of being american
regardless of religion and it's a
necessary component of assimilation for
those deemed outsiders but what do you
guys think is christmas basically the
new fourth of july or has our common
sense been run over by a reindeer let us
know in the comments big thank you to
our patrons who are guaranteed not to
receive cole in their stockings this
year and don't forget to check out our
podcast hit that subscribe button like
it's for the william sonoma mailing list
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you